hallo mein name ist herzlich willkommen
wie heute zu einem neuen video richie
und titel eingeblendet und zwar
kommentare zu meinem körper und zwar
habe ich vor ein paar tagen ein video
hochgeladen kumpel in denen wir auf
einem fußballplatz uns wahrgenommen
haben und abwechselnd probiert haben die
latte zu treffen aus einer entfernung
von elfmetern oder so in dem verlierer
wurde damit seine wasserpistole einfach
straight in die fresse geschossen zu dem
zeitpunkt der videoaufnahme waren es
genau 32 grad dort auf dem fußballplatz
es war eine komplette wiese die sonne
hat einfach nur drauf geknallt aber kein
anderer der gerade sport gemacht hat und
der segen zu beginnen jetzt die schuhe
ausgezogen weil das überhaupt nicht klar
ging es viel zu heiß mit socken und
schuhen und s2 cultra greifen danach
unser kameramann sebastian gesagt dass
wir einfach mal ein t shirt ausziehen
sollten weil es echt richtig heiß werden
sonst sonnenbrand bekommen und nur
bräune irgendwie bis hier und das will
man ja auch nicht mag hat aber trotzdem
licht angelassen jetzt irgendwie nicht
so wärme empfindlich und ich hab dann
halt mein t-shirt ausgezogen und hat
dabei das video oberkörperfrei
aufgenommen und dazu ging es in den
kommentaren ordentlich deswegen habe ich
mir gedacht ich suche mir einfach mal so
ein paar top kommentare raus oder
kommentare die sehr oft geschrieben
wurden und gehe der heute einfach mal
drauf ein der laut spart durch den
bizeps und bauordnung zwölfjährige zu
beeindrucken um das klarzustellen ich
möchte gar keinen irgendwie
beeindruckend ich meine ich hätte mir
ein shirt ausgezogen wenn ihr meinen
oberkörper grün gewesen wäre oder ich
geh 100 kilo wiegen würde das wäre
komplett egal gewesen
der primäre grund warum ich
oberkörperfrei dort stand war nicht um
irgendwie meinen körper zu präsentieren
ich bin nicht mal zufrieden in meinem
körper ich finde ich bin viel zu dünn
aber es waren halt 32 grad und wir
standen in der kompletten sonne also
nerven schreibt er um zwölfjährige zu
beeindrucken so keinen sinn so wenn ich
jemand beeindrucken will dann nur 12
jährige auch zwiebel wolltest du wie du
vor dir hors nein ich weiß nicht wen ich
vor mir habe also war im respekt wie so
beleidigt man direkt rum wenn jemand
oberkörperfrei ein video aufnimmt also
ich habe auch kommentare von freunden
bekommen die auch mal was
dass diese sogar übertreffen ich denke
nur weil ich das machen was ich will
wenn er ins freibad geht zieht ihr dann
auch ein t shirt oder importieren alter
den kommentare gekommen werden von wegen
jo luca kannst du dir vielleicht mal was
anziehen oder irgendwie so war sodann
der inside einfach so die vorlieben vor
dem jeweiligen zuschauer aber so
beleidigungen novell jemand oberkörper
frei steht das kann irgendwas umgefallen
50 der kommentare sind hater die sich
aufregen dass luca oberkörper frei ist
25 sind fan girls 25 sind leute die
gegen gehälter sind und 0% kommentare
oder kritik luca du hast es geschafft
das ist halt genau die sache die ich
gerade auch schon gesagt habe und zwar
wenn wirklich kommentare mit dem
konstruktiven hintergrund gekommen wäre
dann überhaupt kein ding hätte ich
dieses ganze video jetzt gerade gar
nicht machen müssen aber halt wirklich
jeder zweite kommentar war josi dir was
an zulauf
25 von irgendwelchen mädels die
schreiben falls man auf jeden fall mehr
davon und 25 die schreiben hey was regt
euch dann alle so auf da kann halt keine
vernünftige konversation zustandekommen
den kommentaren rhade aus diesem grund
nicht verstehen wie einige große
amerikanische youtuber wie pc einfach
mal für kurze zeit das heißt für kurze
zeit ihre sei mehrere monate gemacht
oder so wir haben ja einfach mal die
kommentare aus gemacht und ich weiß
nicht also ich werde wahrscheinlich
demnächst dazu aber ein video machen so
der kommentare situation weil ich eine
gute idee haben wie ich das ganze den
griff bekommen nein ich werde die
kommentare nicht deaktivieren nicht dass
das irgendwie denkt dass er so aber da
werde ich denke ich in der nächsten
woche war ein video zu machen wir
seitdem auch du congo after okay also
ich habe seit nicht mitgeschrieben leute
die ihn in den kommentaren hätten trauen
es sich in real life nicht in die augen
zu sagen denn da sind die voll die fans
von ihm hört sich jetzt wahrscheinlich
dumm und unglaubwürdig an aber es stimmt
wirklich so ich wurde noch nie von
jemand angesprochen er gesagt hat ihr
euch hast deinen videos und filme das
ist halt das ist halt wirklich der fall
müsste ich ihn am tag 20 minuten video
auf und in der zeit die uns schweiz
kommen willst du noch eine rolle der eco
tarif liegen weil so regt euch nicht auf
wenn da vorne die ganze zeit so saugt
geräusche kommen und so das tut mir leid
und ich hoffe dies letztlich [ __ ]
musste ohne t shirt spielen bei allem
ist
vielleicht ich sagte niebel es oft bei
allem respekt also tut mir leid dass so
oft sagen aber es ist halt wirklich so
die sache ich respektiere ja die leute
die kommentare schreiben und ich weiß
ihr seid alle irgendwie menschen und in
jedem menschen steckt irgendwo was gut
ist aber es gibt so zwei stufen so
erstens jemanden für etwas beleidigen
wasser trieb sollte man nicht machen
aber zweitens jemanden dafür zu
beleidigen und eine beleidigung zu
benutzt die eigentlich gar keine
beleidigung ist das ist halt krass wie
sie politisch [ __ ] weil ich
oberkörperfrei bin also was sagt das
denn über mein sexualleben ist so sexy
ich liebe dein körper ich würde dir so
blasen können bin immer geil wenn ich
dich sehe ok lieber sexy gameboy es ist
wird schöner anfrage denken nicht dass
ich irgendwie mit ich ziehe mir kein t
shirt an sowas provozieren wollte dass
solche fan girls oder fanboys ankommen
und sowas schreiben ich möchte einfach
nur konstruktive kommentare also
wirklich das video war gut du kannst
hier besser schneiden du kannst hier die
color correction bisschen anders machen
lumet riesig hier an der stelle zu stark
aus alles aber das sind so das kann man
nicht verhindern
solche kommentare klar sowas dreht mich
halt einfach auf war die schule haben
will man ziele x t shirt ok ich werde
wieder als schwul beleidigt und als
hampelmann weil ich kein t shirt an habe
sorry also jeder der dann du stiegen in
der dusche ist das dann auch surfe ich
bin unter dem video als auch auf einige
kommentare eingegangen haben einen lauf
sagte jo wenn ihr euch darüber so ab
dass sich oberkörperfrei bin zieht der
dusche dann irgendwie auch ein pulli
anhat dann haben wir auch viele
geantwortet meinen so jana dusche ist
man allein und da wird man nicht gesehen
aber wie macht ihr seinem freibad habt
ihr privates freibad oder also ich finde
es komisch fast alle youtube machen
fußball videos obwohl sie nicht mal was
mit fußball zu tun haben wahrscheinlich
machen sie es nur wenigen klicks weil
fuß bei meiner meinung nach extrem hart
ist wie findet ihr das [ __ ] auf
rechtschreibung ferien also mit fußball
ich komme nicht mehr klar dass weniger
als 1
sache mit fußball ist ich habe selber
sieben jahren verein spielt musste auf
feldwegen 12 verletzungen am knie und
weil ich packe bin so bin ich mein so
was wie lacken schießen oder einfach auf
der straße ein bisschen bolzen das hat
man ja gemacht so bevor der ganzen
youtube zeit wurde schon fußball
gespielt und jeder mag fußball
mittlerweile werden halt mehr videos
davon gemacht was sichert sich aber auch
nicht schlimm finde es geht
wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen mit der
em ein her also man sieht derzeit
relativ viele videos in den youtube
trends also auf der startseite sind
einfach irgendwelche fußball videos von
ece major-turnieren copa américa und so
aber keine ahnung ich will mich dafür
ist auch gar nicht rechtfertigen also es
ist ja nichts verbotenes daran dass man
eine latte schießt challenge hochlädt
oder so ich habe einfach in letzter zeit
gedacht
gaming ist jetzt nicht mehr ganz so
krass meinen natürlich kommt immer noch
gaming weil jeder mensch zockt irgendwie
salz auf dem handy oder auf dem pc oder
whatever aber so einfach wäre viel mehr
spaß also die kamera mit neben irgendwo
hingeht und dann einfach das filmen
worauf man selber bockhardt und
lattenschuss macht einfach spaß und ich
meine wenn ich wirklich auf klicks
gegangen wäre bei dem video dann hätte
ich ja auch irgendwie krasse fussball
challenge genannt oder sowas nicht
einmal genau die dümmsten fußballer so
weil wir einfach ist nicht hingekriegt
haben aus elf metern eine blöde latte zu
treffen was hast du am ellbogen der
aufmerksame zuschauer hat im video
gesehen dass ich hier ein pflaster hatte
das habe ich jetzt mittlerweile aber es
ist einfach so eine schiffe und die habe
ich mir im bett zugezogen ich bin halt
irgendwie blöd über die matratze
gerutscht und dann ist das eben so
aufgeregt und das ist eine brandwand
halten deshalb irgendwie sind so albern
bluten und ich sehr alter halt nicht weh
getan oder so nicht habe das überhaupt
nicht genommen weil ich dachte nicht
dass man etwas passiert wenn ich hatte
an dem tag einen t shirt von max erst an
und auch ein paar klamotten von max hat
nicht so viel mit hatte als team
gefahren und ich wollte das halt nicht
irgendwie mit blut voll machen weil das
über nacht halt immer wieder sich selbst
auch schreibt deswegen hatte ich da
etwas darüber gezogen
du bist echt scheiße auf mit deinen
videos danke für deinen kommentar dorian
nicht nehmen ihr wirklich sehr zu herzen
aber ich höre nicht auf mit videos man
das tut weh auf dem rasen was ein
mädchen in dem video habe ich mich an
einer stelle irgendwie auf den rasen
sind und hat dann gesagt dass vw gerade
das sagen nicht an dem rasen da sind tut
nicht weh also ich weiss nur als ich
früher irgendwie selber noch fußball
gespielt und den kunstrasen spieler
hatten das hat er immer weh getan aber
auf rasen nicht göttlich fußball zu
spielen allerdings hatte ich eine zeit
lang hier oben ultrakurze
rückenschmerzen und habe auch zu dem
zeitpunkt vorher noch wärmepflaster
getragen und wenn man das wärmepflaster
abzieht ist der rücken danach ultra
empfindlich und als ich mich dann auch
den rasen geschmissen habe man ganz nach
unten geknackt und es war wegen
rückenschmerzen und nicht weil ich finde
dass rasen um bequem ist oder so ich
finde ja ein bisschen lächerlich dass er
jetzt jedes mal ein sixpack zeigte mehr
klicks zu bekommen
dazu muss ich zwei sachen sagen uns
jetzt liegt die mine fußballer von ihm
danke mein hund hat mir gerade fußball
vor die tür gelegt was gar keinen sinn
ergibt weil sein jeden hier aus geht es
so die wand fertig wird mich also
erstens ich finde nicht dass ich ein
sixpack habe also man könnte sagen dass
ich bei muskeln haben weil ich trainiere
halt ab und zu im fitnessstudio
allerdings habe ich halten übels
geringen körperfettanteil deswegen ist
bei mir alles direkt definiert für mich
ist es ultra schwer muskeln aufzubauen
das habe ich aber irgendwie mit der zeit
jetzt ein bisschen den griff bekommen
wie ich das hinkriege allerdings sieht
man hat alles direkt also jeder aber
irgendwie wenig warten trainieren oder
sonst irgendwas ich finde jetzt aber
nicht dass ich in krassem körper habe
also ich muss auch wichtig ehrlich
gesagt zu gehen ich war jetzt in den
letzten zwei drei monaten vielleicht
kann ich an einer hand abzählen wie oft
ich im fitnessstudio war weil ich so
viel stress hatte mit autofahren wenn
ihr mir snap chat folgt dann willst du
das wahrscheinlich also das erst mal die
erste sache ich will hier niemand
imponieren weil ich mich nicht mal
selber mit meinem körper imponieren kann
findet und die zweite sache mit den
klicks als ich meine ich stehe hier auch
gerade in t shirt und nur weil man jetzt
oberkörperfrei es heißt ja nicht dass
man mehr klicks macht und ich hab seit
zwei mal gemacht einmal bei meinem
rückenschmerz video wie ich mir das
pflaster auf den rücken geklebt habe
weil t shirt anziehen erstens ultra
wehgetan
diese bewegung mit dem rückfall dass wir
jetzt ein bisschen will und weil ich
zeigen wollte wie ich mir das
wärmepflaster darauf klatsche auf dem
rücken und das weite welt bei dem video
bei 32 grad waren draußen da musste ich
einfach oberkörper frei macht
und freunde ob jetzt verzeihen werden
oder nicht ich werde demnächst auch noch
öfters oberkörperfrei videos machen weil
ich bin beispielsweise wieder mit max im
sommerurlaub und wenn man dann da am
strand und es in dreißig gras und man
will dem video aufnehmen dann dürft ihr
euch selbst entscheiden wollte entweder
ein video haben wo ich am oberkörper
frei haben strand bin und was mache oder
ihr wollt kein johann wenn ich mir denke
ich kann jetzt kein video aufnehmen
oberkörperfrei waren alle wieder hätten
es werden trotzdem noch videos
oberkörper frei kommen das kann ich euch
schon versagt wie hast du den bekommen
den bau einer geburt also ich glaube
dass jeder von uns im bauch bekommen
wenn ich jetzt schon luca zu sehen
luca wird mit c geschrieben es ist ein
echt so man kann so eine blacklist
machen bei youtube dass alle wörter die
in wie man nicht will werden
ausgeblendet ich hab da so was drin wie
[ __ ] und irgendwelche special
giveaway weil die ganzen leute
mittlerweile so viel werbung in den
kommentaren machen ich glaube ich jetzt
auf die blacklist auch mal luca mit k
drauf sodass kommentare mit k einfach
gar nicht mehr angezeigt wäre hallo ich
bin melina und tausche ein nacktbild
gegen abo genau das zum thema leute
schreiben dumme scheiße in die
kommentare also nächste woche kommen ein
video zu den kommentaren wo ich das
ganze mal so ein bisschen ernst da meine
meinung dazu sagen bin 13 uhr genauso
große sixpack herzlichen glückwunsch
also juckt mich nicht
andere machen das von 17 metern wie kate
ja ich mein mann hat im video bei einer
einbindung gesehen wo ich selber die
latte getroffen habe von hinter dem tor
das war auch irgendwie 30 meter oder so
allerdings sind max und ich halt
wirklich nicht die besten lattenschuss
leute also ihr könnt gegen uns gerne
volleyball verpacken oder beer pong oder
zip line mit 180 km/h aber irgend welche
berge weg oder so aber lachen schießen
geld wirklich tatsächlich nicht zu
unseren stärken deswegen aber es hat nur
aus elf michael schubert und selbst das
aber nicht hinbekommen also das ist
irgendwie traurig das war vom video
meine damen und herren ich habe
eigentlich noch
ca 20 andere kommentare mir aussuche
allerdings sind das wirklich alles
kommentare wo wirklich leute so
schreiben schwul kann sie mein t shirt
anziehen sobald alles also ich denke da
bin ich jetzt schon oft genug und lange
genug drauf eingegangen denn euch dieses
video hier gefallen hat mich auf die
kommentare reagiert habe freue ich mich
über eine bewertung ich finde das
eigentlich ganz leise wenn videos krass
diskutiert werden und darunter sind an
die 12.000 kommentaren gewesen dass man
sich dann auch wenn man die kommentare
raus nimmt uns ein bisschen darauf
eingeht einerseits um euch vielleicht
etwas zu erklären weil wenn es viele
kommentare gibt gibt es oft irgendeinem
erklärungs klärungsbedarf things und
andererseits halt einfach um das ganz
neue revue passieren zu lassen und dass
ich meine meinung so ein bisschen
präsentieren kann also wenn euch das
video gefallen hat freue ich mich über
jede bewertung von euch schreibt mir
meine kommentare was eure meinung zu der
kompletten debatte dazu jetzt ist